hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to alien isolation a game
that i've been very eager to play and a
lot of people out there have been
very eager for me to play because it's
proving to be
an actual scary horror game
and i think that's about right right
there which i'm actually very interested
in because i have not played a scary
aliens game since aliens versus predator
2.
the human campaign on that game and that
game in general was one of my favorite
alien games of all time just because
when you were playing the human campaign
both the predators
and the aliens were after you and they
wanted to kill you
very dead they wanted you dead and
everything was
wrong and everything was terrifying and
there was like the motion sensor the
first time i saw
a report of the commercial starship
nostromo
third officer reporting that's sigourney
weaver
the other members of the crew
kane lambert
parker brett
ash and captain dallas
are dead i shouldn't be smiling that
they're dead but this is a
loser speech from the end of the first
period ship destroyed
i should reach the frontier in about six
weeks
with a little luck the network will pick
me up
this is ripley
last survivor of the nostromo yes
signing off yes
i'm very excited i'm a big alien fan
like i love the whole movie
i've seen almost every movie even the
strange ones
that weren't so good like alien vs
predator and alien vs predator 2 the
movie
the game alien vs predator 2 was great
fantastic love playing every campaign
the movies they got weird quick hello
ripley yes
huh i'm samuels i work for the company
you're a robot i can tell
it's about your mother we think we may
have found her amanda
uh-huh you got a british accent you're
definitely a robot
a commercial vessel the anissa dora has
recovered what we believe to be the
flight recorder unit of the nostromo
um where
zeta reticular
what did it tell you we don't know
the unit was taken to sevastopol station
it's proprietorial material so the
company wants it to be collected as soon
as possible
sevastopol's a supply depot in the
region it's uh
a permanent free port i know what it is
yeah
okay so i'm deranged
there's a courier ship called the
torrens heading out that way in two days
we're going to travel out we me
and another exec and you if you're
willing
look ripley when this job came across my
desk
i read the case history
i know why you're working in the region
where she went missing
you're still looking aren't you
i've been cleared to offer you a place
on the torrents
if you want to come along
maybe there'll be some closure for you
but i'm excited
i'm excited to play i'm a huge nerd
about alien stuff
like is it wrong for me to be excited
that things are gonna go horribly bad
and i'm gonna be left in the lurch in
the edge of space
all alone and i know that guy's a robot
because in every aliens movie
well not the not the first two but in
prometheus which is technically in the
alien universe
uh it's actually like a prequel to
aliens
um the guy had the robot had a british
accent and
then it's like i got a feeling that
guy's a robot he may not look it right
now but
yo you'll see i i can tell who's the
robot i intentionally did not find out a
lot about this game i did not know
that i was actually playing as ripley's
daughter and i don't know if that's some
retcon [ __ ] going on
explore the taurens okay
let's start exploring the torrens get
dressed
oh i'm naked oh okay well
whoopsie-doopsy i shouldn't be walking
around this ship all nakey
all righty then what do i need to do
there's a lot of glowing green lights
are those important
oh oh i'm taking a sensual shower i
thought that might have been the get
dressed machine
ripley has a very manly singing voice in
case you guys didn't know that
okay shower over am i supposed to do
something is there a map button
aha oh there we go right there okay is
this one
yeah that's the one it's glowing green
and it's glowing orange
i'm so excited i don't even know why i
don't care if this game's bad i'm
playing a
actually well wait was i not supposed to
do that
of everlane connor samuels taylor and
ripley
so there's five people on board the ship
where the hell are they why am i here
all alone
why is she reading a weird fashion
museum from the 80s
oh look at that look at that this this
game is so
80s just like the first movie i mean
that was back when
sci-fi was seen through the lens of
technology from that day and you can see
how it emulates
the future emulates technology from that
time and obviously like
if you watch sci-fi movies from today
you'll see that that
emulates stuff from that time so very
interesting
lm link i mean look at this computer
holy crap this computer is from straight
out of the 80s god it's awesome
uh for laying you on the lookout for the
navigational officer ivy friend that's
just lost his ship and he's looking for
work i can vouch for him he's got good
papers
same old stories my corpse undercut him
pick the bus with clients
blah blah blah blah blah drop by the
docks um
so wayland yutani blaine
okay so wayland whalen corp um
was that the corp that was introduced in
prometheus or was that already there i
can't remember
which one is but the guy weyland i
believe
uh was from oh speak to taylor
speak to samuels i guess i'll go to
samuel's first oh hello
hello oh these are looking very
very like samurai suits why are there
samurai space suits in here
unless we're just very very japanese on
this ship hello
hello how's it going in there is that uh
you're the robot guy aren't you hello
ripley samuels did you wake up early
well i don't really need as much sleep
as the rest of you is such a robot just
inspecting the torrens facilities
a well-maintained ship i realize it's a
very similar model to
the nostromo uh-huh yes m-class
a later pattern i've worked engineering
jobs on ships like this
of course is taylor up yet
she's not a seasoned traveler hyper
sleep may have been punishing for her
i haven't seen her i'll go check on her
okay so i gotta speak with taylor and
samuels
is most definitely a robot or there's a
little bit of trouble because he was
looking
just a little over here to the side of
my head
and he was a bit robotic in his
movements i don't know if that's just
the game
but i won't question it too much oh i'm
playing
okay never mind i need to stop flipping
out because there's been
where am i going there's been multiple
attempts at making aliens game and this
one has a lot of hype behind it
and i've intentionally not found out a
lot about the game mostly because i want
to
taylor let it be exploded it's certainly
not good
and i very much doubt it's mourning
either yeah
someone's a grumpy bush i feel like
death
i don't know how you people put up with
hypersleep regularly you get used to it
i don't do long-haul very often most
legal execs don't travel further than
the coffee machine
i'm surprised whelan yutani felt the
need to send legal at all
the loss of the nostromo and its cargo
cost the company a lot of money
it's important we find out what happened
if i can close the case with a
conclusive accident report
it'll look great with my superiors okay
i'm sorry
that was insensitive realize
your mother has been missing for 15
years and you
it's okay we'll both get what we want
right
have you seen samuels yes he's probably
been up for hours
yeah i know cause he's a robot and i
also wonder why everyone eats
approaching only station who the hell is
that
go to the bridge for briefing what
briefing
are there aliens on board are they
aliens to be seen
excuse me lady you need to walk a little
bit faster
as much as i look whoa okay as much as i
like staring
uh at your behind i really want to
progress in the story
hello my name is ripley
a ripley am i uncomfortably close to you
that is a lovely blouse
can we get to be briefed yet hope you
all had a restful journey
no the torrance is in very good order
for an old m-class captain thanks mr
robot
when i bought her took a few years and a
lot of contracts to refit
she pays for herself now you said we're
approaching sebastopol station
are we docking i believe your contact is
marshall weights is that right
i'll hail sevastopol and arrange
boarding with him good
let's get this done don't worry miss
taylor routine
in and out connor how are we doing
awesome g loaded and calibrated approach
vector locked who the hell are you
so i can say hello channel open captain
does everyone
hi what are you doing what are you doing
there approaching the monitors
you didn't think anyone was watching you
over here did you well i'll just leave
you to it
excuse me lady i need uh uh lady late
okay then i'll just go through you
this whole thing feels strange oh
space i love space
i love space i love space games space
games are by far my favorite
i love anything about space space is
like my one weakness
i love mass effect is like my favorite
game series of all time
and it's just like oh space i love
space i sound like the space personality
cube
space okay anyway so i just i have a
i have space chasms all of the time was
i supposed to be doing something
i was not listening to that briefing at
all i was freaking out about sci-fi here
okay anyway so what's my objective
collect your
oh collect my briefing document okay
that seems important
i got an achievement i'm awake oh space
wow i am i'm just the biggest loser when
it comes can we see
it switch to monitors
sevastopol station uh
is that damage it looks like damage
punch-up 74 tight angle uh-oh
looks like the dry dock bay is screwed i
can't bring the torns into that
this is a commercial vessel turns out
clear registration number
msv 7760 calling sebastian traffic
control
we're carrying three passengers on a
whaling yutani bond
you're holding the nostromo flight
recorder unit we request immediate
permission to transfer the passenger's
port side over
i'm assuming they're screaming at us to
turn back and i actually forgot i need
to turn on subtitles for you guys just
in case i'm talking over something i
don't know
seem pretty screwed up so our fitted
samuel suit with a radio booster
i can only keep the torns in transit for
24 hours
you'll have heard from us by then uh-huh
in our samurai space suits
thank you we will we got a wow that is
one
badass suit stand by my contract doesn't
cover bloody space walks
that's the only option and it's
perfectly safe if you do what i tell you
yeah actually let me turn on subtitles
right now i i don't want to skip the i
don't want to skip it if escape skips it
i don't want to do that but
i'm usually very good about keeping
subtitles on it
what's moisturizing hating this just
shadow me taylor
you too samuels affirmative thanks mr
robot
i really don't know if this is
pre-rendered or not i think it would be
pre-rendered just because
you know there are certain scenes that
look really good that they need to make
pre-rendered but what happened
this is all live live rendered
you're doing good too
just keep moving that's not good
samuels taylor respond
anybody oh
huh
they did a really good job of emulating
the sound so that the only the sound
transferred of what she was touching
that's a really nice touch that's a nice
touch because obviously there's no sound
in space but if you were in your suit
you would hear things that vibrate
through the physical contact that you
make through things so that was good
right there
wow space i love it i'm gonna turn on
the subtitles as soon as i can like
right now i'm gonna
no i can't escape out of this i gotta i
gotta get through this
it's like waking up in uh mass effect 3
and that one scene that i won't spoil
just in case anyone else played it but
yeah
oh i'm guessing this is where the
isolation comes in
but then i found out that taylor and the
robot guy actually did make it onto the
ship and i got to re
conorder with them later dawn
subtitles on there we go got it okay
subtitles are on sorry everybody about
that
uh my my apology i'm usually very good
about that okay
oh yes find help
um i don't think there's gonna be much
help in
here mostly
because help is probably being garbled
up by an
alien with acid blood oh boy
hey look it's another kind of samurai
suit i wonder why it has heavy armor on
it
seems rather excessive well i mean in
space even a little bit of a debris
usually
is flying around at several thousand
miles per hour so it's probably bad
they will warn you if enemies are nearby
enemies
oh well well we're into it now
i really hope this game does live up to
the hype that is built up in my mind
i mean most of the hype in my mind is
because
space but i'm really eager to see
what kind of horrors await me here
okay let's get into it alright serious
mode here serious mode
too much excitement going on
well that couldn't have been a good
sound
yeah i'm guessing that fire on board a
spaceship is not a good thing
can i go this way i probably don't want
to
but okay i can't go that way so i got to
go this way
excuse me excuse me is somebody out
there
some alien i don't even have a
flashlight right now so i gotta depend
on
entirely everything in front of my face
so
wait a minute no this is wrong i just
went in a big circle where was i
supposed to go
uh i guess i gotta go some way over here
um can i jump over something
can i leap over these up there had to be
something to do with that fire i gotta
find a way to turn it off or something
it's gotta be like a gas line or
something or other or maybe i just jump
oh hello
i didn't even see this okay climb into
the butthole port
oh boy
i'm like eager i'm eager for something
to scare me that's that's how much i
want
i want this game to work out it's so
dark i can't even see anything
which is a good thing by the way
i'm just afraid that i'm building it up
too much in my mind and it's not going
to scare me at the end of it because i
really do want to be scared and i've
been playing scary game for about i
don't know
two and a half years now so i'm
very ready what does this say
sevastolink
okay then all right folder corrupted
shared um so boys and girls you probably
heard the whispers about sebastopol now
by
by now and i can confirm it's official
the basketball is being
decommissioned so the station itself was
a few weeks away from
retirement before everything went to
[ __ ]
uh does not mean lucky dip everything
here has to be accounted for and i will
personally escort anyone found helping
themselves to equipment to marshall
awaits
okay then folder corrupted okay so the
whole station was about to be
decommissioned before an
alien found its way on board and
everything
was terrible okay
now we
where am i going to stop i mean oh
what i can't see a damn thing i thought
i was being dragged for a second there
oh it is dark in here is that a flare do
i need that thank you very much
damn yeah goddamn this will help with
oh i haven't oh i didn't even know i had
an inventory
okay so how do i use mouse to select i
am selecting
hard activate okay there we go got it
hey that's ominous and horrifying
the red light somehow doesn't make me
feel any better
okay okay so i could throw it or hold it
or whatever
what does that do okay how do i crouch
there we go can i go through here
yes i can someone you
always know working
blah blah blah i like how there's a lens
flare in my eyeball
it's all very stylized i gotta give it
that okay
so climb up here no i gotta keep moving
then
it reminds me when the first time i
played dead space because i have no idea
what's
going on in the game but i have a very
good idea of what's going to happen
now dead space kicked it off a lot
earlier it was like the approach into
the game
that is an scg injector
why do i have that why do i need that am
i about to start dosing up with drugs
very soon scrap
i can craft i don't know if that's a
good thing or a bad thing
crafting was in dead space three i don't
know if it added or took away from the
game
i'm gonna go ahead and say it took away
where am i supposed to go
wait hang on i'm not exactly sure where
i'm supposed to be what is
that okay there's gotta be something
else there because obviously this way is
blocked up so there needs to be
something heroes supposed to ah i didn't
see that before there was a button here
that i could have pressed probably
though ah there we go
sorry i missed it it's very dark i can't
see anything in front of my face
i actually really really liked the first
dead space when i first played through
that
it was like a magical experience it was
thoroughly scary to me
uh when i first played even though a lot
of people say when you have guns it
takes away from the horror of it and i
would say
that the farther down you go in the dead
space series it gets less scary
but a lot of people made some pretty
good observations that uh it wasn't so
much that the game became less scary
it's that
you're playing isaac clark the whole
time and isaac clark
anyone here probably not and you don't
want to be shouting that
or whispering it even but isaac clark
was the same character in all the games
and isaac clarke has faced these before
the first game was the scariest because
isaac clark had never seen him before he
didn't know how to deal
the second one he was going very much
insane but he kind of knew what he was
doing but things were still new
the second one was still very scary uh
not as scary as the first in my opinion
but the third one
was when he was like a seasoned badass
okay so i gotta find a way to restore
the power it is dark as
crap in here so he was a seasoned badass
and he
was well versed in it but if i have not
played the co-op campaign then i
actually think i
i want to mostly because okay so i just
got to spam this
come on power baby
that's pretty amazing crank there if
that powers up the whole thing
kill a kilojoule votes okay
terminal here because i want to play the
co-op campaign because
some people say that the co-op campaign
was much scarier than the first one
because
you were playing carver who had never
dealt with the necromorphs really okay
anyway
if you're looking for a sash i moved it
0-3-4-0
so that's probably important i need to
find that oh three four zero i'll try to
remember that
no no no no no no get back in there get
back in there i need to see things
okay come on come on come on
uh goodbye from skids and we've had a
long journey together but sadly it's
coming to an end seeks and corp will
take this like to take this opportunity
to thank all you so that's after the
whole
place is being decommissioned they're
saying hey that's okay
working joe androids will be there in
striffs but whoa okay
harris harris turner get back here now
we have a track somewhere in engineering
lock the terminal down
kill the power and don't forget your
reports make them thorough we're going
to need our paperwork to be bulletproof
when this shit's over
okay whatever you say okay restore power
to departures is that an objective for
me or is that just
anything in general oh three four zero
got to remember that
oh and save the game yes indeed
yes please all right so now we're
getting in the thick of it
now we're getting the very interesting
part i thought i restored power
didn't i i did maybe i got restore power
in a few other places um
yeah okay there's more power relays in
here that i gotta pump up manually with
my
big strong meaty arms and also that
seems pretty bad
i'm just assuming i gotta backtrack
because i can't seem to find anything
else here
it's not just that it's dark i've looked
in every nook and cranny there's gotta
be something
uh way in the back that'll help me
restore power i just gotta find another
one of those cranky dudes
and crank it up and then get power and
be able to move forward because
i'm assuming the only reason i'm able to
backtrack at all is because
it wants me to
oh i'm dumb okay the term whoa who was
that wait a minute whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa
who was that oh i'm an idiot in the
terminal there was an option to change
the power i was wandering around for
like
five ten minutes i was like where do i
need to go what do i need to do i'm a
big dum-dum
so sorry about that i'm i'm an idiot so
uh let's just find out who the hell was
running over here
um there happened to be an alien of some
sort
who is trying to kill you dead is that a
thing that's happening there don't mind
me i'm just gonna steal all your stuff
and then move on my way because
i have no idea what i'm doing in here
bye everybody
okay bye i guess and also i seem to
notice that
people
i can't hear that okay so let's just
keep moving forward because i've been
staying in one spot for way too long i
ain't touching that
no way no how well that seems bad
who's uh who's a shaky shaky
who's a rumbly wumbly hello what
happened here
yeah it's a good question also am i
outside of jupiter is that just another
gas giant
somewhere somewhere well then this seems
awfully morbid
i'm gonna keep trying to find out the
mystery of this place but
i don't think it's gonna work out very
hard for me
so i just need to take the lesson that
obviously in these computer terminals
they have the option to help me out
progress on my way
and not be an idiot and not use the
options that are
hello who the hell are you
oh are you the ship i was just on
captain we're in i'm right here
we're lame yeah yeah she'll hear you
okay
no no that's that's the thing that needs
to happen
or not who's that okay i thought i saw
something over there
that needs to not happen all right then
that's bad
well i greatly suspect that things are
about to get fricked up
all right then i'll just be on my way as
per usual oh an air hockey table
that lovely oh there we go restore power
in the cranky yankee
this is like that flashlight from craven
manor i just need to shake it
really hard so that it'll work there we
go
bing-bong we're good okay whoa what the
hell
oh they're behind curtains i thought
they were just low resolution for a
little bit there
whoa
aha that seems bad
okay who's in here
huh why is that shaking around
who did that who's here
who's hiding i'm a scary monster
jones today's update after numerous
demands marsha waits finally called a
public meeting to address the rumors
that have been circulating on sevastopol
but instead of the answers we wanted he
continued to be evasive and after only a
few minutes he and his team were pelted
by projectiles from an angry crowd
a gun was fired there was panic and now
weights and what's left of his team
are forcibly ejecting us from the
terminal feels like we're on our own now
probably a bad thing i mean the name of
the game is alien isolation so you don't
want to be alone in this situation
i would laugh if there's just one alien
around here that's
causing havoc hello somebody down there
excuse me while i just walk on
nothingness does anybody want to
announce themselves
before i oh oh i don't know if i was
supposed to come down here
and damn is it dark again why has it got
to be dark every single place i go
hello
ooh shaking lights very spooky
hello aliens
okay nothing yet i've been playing this
game for a while now
nothing has popped out at me i'm
guessing it's just building the
damn place is falling apart i'm guessing
it's just building the ambiance which
you gotta understand
why is it falling apart what possible
damage could those aliens have done
to cause everything to go to [ __ ] this
actually looks like a level straight out
of dead space
how do i get over oh i need to climb
through that oh okay
so i gotta move this excuse me sir
and of course i gotta climb through as
many confined spaces as possible
yay come on i want something to happen
before i end this episode
something pop out of me don't
cough something's gonna pop out of me
something's gonna happen
was that a person i thought it was
come back here i got some questions for
you like what the hell happened here
why the hell is everything going to crap
and what are you going to do about this
situation is there's something in there
that i need
linglong hello oh you aren't important
at all
something here i know i'm right on the
edge of something happening
right on the edge but this episode has
been going on for quite a while
i may take a little bit of a break here
oh but i want something
power come here you give me your power
there we go got it bing-bong well that
sounds almost comforting
that doesn't
okay anyway i think i gotta end this
episode here i've been playing for
like 42 minutes now including the part
where i was just wandering around like
an idiot but either way
uh that's all i got for now thank you
all so much for watching click the
invitation for more videos that i've
done and let me know what you think of
this game in the comments below because
i don't know a thing about this if
you've seen other people play it or you
play it yourself
don't spoil anything uh but let me know
if there's things that i should watch
out for or things that you like about
the game or tell me
uh what you think of it in general
because everything leading up to this
was saying that it was going to be a
very scary game and i
really want to know a lot about it so
either way thank you all so much for
watching click the entertain more videos
that i've done i've already said that
and as always
i will see you in the next video
bye-bye oh that's disgusting
hi hey
on your face